what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout I'm really excited to be
here with a friend of mine his name is
skip Prichard how to introduce this man
I think Renaissance man is maybe the the
easiest of scriptura though although he
he'll be much more humbled and won't
accept that title but but he is a CEO he
is a speaker he is a friend he is a
blogger he is an author he's got a new
book out that we're gonna talk about
today the book of mistakes and one of
the reasons I love this guy is every
time I'm with him I learned something it
makes me think I go home a better person
because of it and to this guy's a
studier he is a learner and for me I
love modeling success you know you see
the people behind on the wall you guys
watch the videos most of what I do is
focused around success so the top 10 was
a success skip has a different approach
which is why I love him he's focusing on
mistakes and so his new book talks about
the nine most common mistakes that come
up over and over and over again that
prevent you from having success so
without further ado skip welcome aboard
man thanks it's great to be here I love
already I'm feeling your energy that's
the thing I know about you and I met you
in person in Madrid of all places and so
you podcasts are doing this YouTube
right live in the streets of Madrid and
got to hear you speak you were amazing
inspired us all I love it I love it so
so tell me about the Y so we've got this
book coming out the book of mistakes
it comes out February 6 on Tuesday we're
excited
so it's pre-order right now we have the
link in description guys can check it
out tell me about the why for this book
why did you write this why is it
important the why behind it is that we
all make mistakes and the mistakes tend
to follow us and you know it's doing a
lot of research I've interviewed over a
thousand of the most successful people
in the world and I was doing some
research into regrets when the people
are near death and you'll find that many
people will say you know here's what I
regret here's here's what mistakes what
I made and I've always been fascinated
by people's mistakes and failures and
also their successes and that study is
kind of the why behind this and I'm
excited to put it all into a book that
people can die
Justin and learn from I love it now now
there's nine mistakes and I think the
hardest thing for me in prepping for
this is picking which ones to talk about
because I know we're on a time limit and
I like all of them so I picked I picked
my favorite three that I want to dive a
little deeper with you the first one was
a mistake number one working on someone
else's dream and I see this so much a
lot of my audience they're entrepreneurs
or they're wannabe entrepreneurs trying
to get out of the the nine-to-five to go
do their own thing how do you break the
mindset how do you get out of that zone
of working for somebody else taking that
safe job and doing your thing like how
do you get the push to do it what do you
think well working on someone else's
dream were so often you know I was
talking about people who have these
regrets later in life oftentimes they'll
cyclist they'll say I wish I would have
been more true to me I wish I would have
been more myself and so often we're
swept up into someone else's dream where
we're told what to major in maybe by our
parents or were pushed into our first
job and then we're you know why did you
end up in marketing well that's what my
first manager kind of encouraged me to
to get into and so we you know it's the
natural pull of the current is to get
swept up into somebody else's dream and
yet inside us we have something that we
want to get out and that dream may be a
business it may be a book it may be a
song there's something in us and I think
you're right so so many times we just
drift and you have to stop yourself from
that drift tick you end up somewhere
that you don't want to be and you have
to be cognizant so the first thing is to
recognize where you are in that process
and to think about your dream and to
think about am i living my dream or
someone else's dream and you can be
working even for someone else and still
be successful because it could be part
of your dream to support that mission
you may be you may be passionate about
the same thing which is great but you
don't want to end up in a place where
hey all the work that I'm putting in all
my passion is dead because I'm really
not working on what's inside of me so
how do you get the confident - the
courage or the Mojo or whatever it is -
to stop doing the safe thing
somebody else's dream and go off and do
your path I think that's where a lot of
people are stuck how do they summon the
courage to go off and do it you know
I've asked a lot of entrepreneurs how do
they do it I asked leaders what gave you
the courage to do it and the answers are
as varied as the people that you'll talk
to but it's finding that within you know
one of the things that I talk about in
the book is readiness and to me it's so
very important before you begin the
journey of the nine mistakes
it starts with readiness and what I say
in there is readiness is when your
desire is greater than your distraction
let all of us have these distractions
and you can work on both sides of this
equation right desire and distraction
you need to limit the distractions so if
you want to write you just got to write
every day and get rid of the
distractions if you want to start a
business you've got to get rid of the
distractions the naysayers - critics at
the same time you need to increase your
desire right what do you desire to do is
it a burning desire or is it just
something that's kind of floating by me
and kind of like I'd like to do that
someday is it your passion this is my
desire so I like to work on both sides
of those a quick of that equation
increasing my desire and making sure
that it's true
and decreasing these distractions so
readiness is when your desire is greater
than your distraction and there's a
whole formula for working that otherwise
if you start too early right your
distractions are gonna stop you right
first negative relative calls you and
says hey what are you doing that for and
you're just yeah you're right know if
you're prepared and your desires strong
enough you can overcome any distraction
I love that when your desire is greater
than your distraction I could see a
whole social media campaign for you
launching around that thank you that's
when you're ready yeah I love it
now you're talking a lot about regret
here and this was sowing going through
the book it's interesting because regret
seems to come up in various ways through
the number of rules or mistakes but it's
not its own rule it's not it's own
mistake it's not like so is regret
mistake number 10 is that is that a new
book for you or is it is it just just
ingrained in every single
how do you see like where does regret
fit in terms of mistakes well regret is
something that if you study that it's if
you're making these mistakes you're
gonna end up with regrets and we all
have failures right we talked about that
you and I've talked about that if you
fail it's okay if you're not failing
enough that means you're not trying
enough if just make sure you fail
quickly right you want to get back on
your feet
regret comes when you're failing and
failing and failing and you're pulled
into someone else's mission someone
else's purpose not true to myself so
regret can happen with all of the nine
mistakes if you continue to make them
and you don't change you're gonna end up
and regret but if you pull and you have
the discipline to get to work on your
own desires and dreams then you're not
going to have those regrets
the key to regrets just like failure you
can have them have them every day just
happen quickly I you know some people
say oh I have no regrets I have a lot of
regrets every year I think about what do
what do I regret because those are the
things I'm studying so I can say you
know what I'm gonna learn from that I
don't want to waste this time I regret
that I spent time with this these people
who weren't pulling me into my dream but
we're kind of pulling me off course so
whatever your regrets are you can learn
from them like embrace them study them
it's like failure you can you can use
all that as fuel to get you to where you
want to be I love it I love the energy
alright cool cool this is great so I
want to jump to mistake number three and
that was accepting excuses and I think
with mistake number one which was
working someone else's dream people
acknowledge that they working on
somebody else's dream but they don't
have the courage or know how to actually
go out and do it with the excuses I find
people don't have the awareness they're
just accepting it they don't know that
they're making excuses they don't take
responsibility for their life so how do
you get the awareness that you know what
this reason of why I can't go start my
own business or why I can't get that
promotion or whatever the thing that
they want to do but that that wall in
between them how do you recognize that
that's just an excuse and not just the
fact we we all can think that they're
facts right so I've seen people who will
say well excuses the weather I have I'm
married to someone who's negative friend
of mine's negative taxes
or too much oh I don't have the capital
to start this money's a problem we have
all these excuses you know when I
started thinking about this I
interviewed rich Gaspari rich Gaspari
was a former mr. universe he is the CEO
of gaspari nutrition you'll find his
products throughout the world in all of
his nutritional products but here I met
him and decades later after he had been
this amazing bodybuilder he said I'm
going to be on the cover of a
bodybuilding magazine I mean this is
when people would be like you know
you're middle-aged and washed up etc and
he goes I'm gonna make that cover and he
wrote a book called no excuses and and I
met him and he got himself into the same
shape that he did in his 20s and got on
the cover and and I thought wow like
what excuses could you have he is
determined and I thought that same thing
isn't about bodybuilding it's really
about building a life right what kind of
life do we make whatever those excuses
are we're all gonna have them too tired
I have a great show I want to binge on
Netflix you know all of these reasons
will stop us so we have to look at the
excuses for where we are if you can't
get past this there are always these
excuses they're always going to pull you
off of course you're gonna create them
what I say in the book is this the most
important microphone in the world don't
say this part but it's not the one in
front of Evan right now the most
important microphone in the world is the
one inside your mind guarded with
everything yet you have because the
voice inside is either stepping up to
that microphone and making excuses or
providing reasons for you to succeed and
so guard that microphone because it's
those voices inside that voice inside
that's much more determinative of your
faith than these voices outside guard
that microphone it's either stepping up
and giving you excuses or it's saying I
can do this I can find a way around this
yes I don't have this but I'm going to
figure it out yes other people have
dealt with this but they have also
figured it out
there are some people who say oh I I
just can't you know the big one is money
oh the constraints and money and time
and my job and my kids and they come up
with all these reasons and yet you can
get these lists of all these people pad
all those same things and they
experience the success why is that
because they've reframed all of those
into you know what I can get through
this I'm going to use this and in fact
people that if you interview people as I
have on creativity they will say that
the most creative people whether in
business whether in the arts they have
constraints it's it's amazing if you
look at some of the most successful
companies today that are flush with cash
they're not innovating anymore they just
take that money and buy other companies
right the biggest innovation usually
happens not always there's no general
rule but usually happens when you have
these constraints of capital of time etc
so the people that use these excuses to
stop them and other people use the
excuses as these constraints to figure
out a better way more efficient and I
think that's a major difference in how
you talk to yourself so how do we
prevent the trap of falling back into it
so so if you guys pick up the book you
you see that chapter you you acknowledge
wow I'm making those mistakes I'm you
know I'm telling myself in that
microphone I'm holding myself back and
you read it and you feel it but then you
know when you've done the book when you
move on to the next chapter or the next
week or the next month it's easy to fall
back into the old habits an old way of
talking to yourself what do you
recommend to keep that as a consistent
habit well one big thing is what are you
fueling in mind with what are you
listening to right are you listening to
the the greatest youtubers who are gonna
teach you to believe your teeth are you
listening to great podcasts that are
gonna feed your mind are you reading
things that are going to lift you up so
you have to continually guard that I
mean too often if you leave that
microphone unguarded you're just filling
your mind up with things that will take
you the opposite direction so watch what
you're reading writing scene etc and if
you surround yourself with all of these
great voices that are filling you up
it's gonna keep you on track and have
somebody that you're accountable to who
will just stop you'll be like well you
know what happened to you you're getting
real negative and pull you back in and
and that's why you'll see so many people
will will be in that same group and
they're all enthused and it's because
they're feeding off of each other's
energy now I also wrote a leaders guide
to the book of mistakes which is
available on the book of mistakes calm
that helps with some of these strategies
to keep you on track I love it
I want to jump to the last mistake
mistaken number nine and what's great
about this you guys haven't seen this
yet because this is the the preview copy
that
skip sent me it shows it like it's super
clear so you got you know mistake number
nine and then what the mistake is and
then a quick like it's really motivating
reading that page and then there's a lot
more content behind it
mistake number nine believing you have
all the time in the world and so just an
idea of like making today count that I'm
not going to put off my dream until
tomorrow I'm not gonna wait till next
month or next year that like today it's
got to happen today
talk to me about the importance and why
people make this mistake so often we
make it because so often especially when
we're young and broke and I was there we
think the most important thing is
perhaps money or who are acquiring
things but the actual most valuable
thing in the world is time because time
escapes us all and I remember years ago
I took this personality test we all take
these and I remember I took this Evan
and I got a zero on patience they said
you have a zero like we're used to
people maybe getting a low score or you
know kind of skewing the norm but you
have a zero and I felt awful and I
always heard people say to me oh you
know you need to develop patience and
all this and I was kind of gone by it
I'm telling the instructor I'm like you
know what do I do about this and he said
this is the greatest thing you could ask
for
he reframed the whole thing I said what
do you mean he said it means you have
the highest sense of urgency that
could possibly before and so I thought
wow you know you just reframed it for me
I now have the highest sense of urgency
and that urgency is so important I have
seen successful product launches
successful acquisitions of companies
successful launches of big new
initiatives or new businesses be fueled
by that sense of urgency and
entrepreneurs especially happen they
don't have this on you know we'll get to
it etc usually the larger the
bureaucracy the slower it is and we tend
to not have that same sense of urgency
well there's this process and have you
put it through this forum and this
folder instead of thinking about I've
got to get this done right now I've
gotta love this well the same thing in
our lives right why not get to it today
why not say you know what I'm going to
determine that these things that I have
in my goals I'm going to make them
happen no matter what
and I'm going to have this determination
to get it done now if you don't have
that deadline you know life passes you
by and you say well you know I can get
to that later and then it's too late my
grandmother used to have this plaque and
it was something like too soon old too
late smart well you know that happens to
us all right we're too soon old too late
smart and that was kind of a theme in
these mistakes so you know what let's
reverse that let's get you let's get
smart now and then we can enjoy being
old Limor there right let's not wait
until we're too old to get smart why not
take it on right now why not start that
business this year why not start writing
that book you want to write right now
why not launch the product you want to
launch right now why not start listening
to the three podcasts tune into the top
youtubers who are gonna really enthuses
watch these channels except today why do
we have to wait we don't that's the
magic of all of this it can happen today
why wait a year you can start taking the
steps you need to make to where you want
to go today right now right here there's
no reason to wait you don't
you have the perfect education the
perfect capital lined up the perfect
situation unravel the perfect genius
idea why wait just start on something
right now and yes you'll make some
mistakes yes you'll make some failures
but the magic of it all is that you can
tweak it learn from it fail quickly
change the course of where you're gonna
go and that to me is so very key to your
success believing you have all the time
in the world it's a big one you it's
central to get go I love I think we need
to take that last like three minute rant
and just cut that out and and that's
that could be a alarm clock for people
on the book of mistakes calm wake up to
that message every day I love it
guys I want to get to some questions
from you guys we've got about 10 minutes
left with skip so if you have a question
leave it in the chat it's blowing up
people are already saying learning
somebody thinks you guys thank you so
much this is amazing you're awesome so
we're getting tons of feedback tag me in
the comments if you have a question for
skip first one coming in is from feel
good within skip how do you overcome
your fear will feel good within how do
you overcome the fear you know I think
there's there's so many ways and part of
it is just doing it you know one of the
mistakes is about being in your comfort
zone and if you're in your comfort zone
you're not afraid and you're also not
growing right and and I think you've got
to learn to be afraid of not growing
you've got to think you know what if I'm
comfortable and everything's good
there's something wrong how do I use the
prime time in my life to develop and
change that and so you've got to push
yourself to the edge of your comfort
zone and then a little beyond right what
makes you uncomfortable a lot of people
are afraid of speaking right so go out
and start speaking join Toastmasters
join some organization that will help
them speak if that's what you're afraid
of
because conquering your fears really
will give you that confidence that will
feel so much in their life and you know
everything everything that we do we can
have fear right I had this book coming
out on Tuesday and I have the natural
fear oh well you know what will people
think will they like it etc well we all
have those fears and it's
gently pushing and doing these things
that will then give you the confidence
to keep going I love it
Ben is asking quick question where can I
get this book what's the best place for
people to get it on pre-order the book
of mistakes comm is my website but you
can get it everywhere
ebooks physical books nationally
airports it'll all be out on Tuesday
Barnes & Noble books a million indie
book stores around the world that I love
amazon.com all all of the places you'd
normally get books the book of mistakes
9 secrets to creating a successful
future look for that red ribbon and you
know you got it yeah it's nice it looks
like this is bookmark here this red
ribbon across the top it's it's unique
it's on the side spine too so you can
see it this whole there's also a whole
bunch of free bonuses that we'll talk
about later on at the end but we've also
linked it up down the scription you guys
can check it out Michael is saying skip
what is the best way to start mentoring
others now I know you do a lot of
leadership stuff we haven't really
touched on it here but I know that's a
huge passion of yours how can you start
mentoring people how does how does the
mistake book kind of fit into that theme
as well well well the mistake book fits
into that because the leadership guide
in particular will take you through how
do you how do you mentor people there's
also questions for a book club it's a
great book to read and kind of work with
people and learn what's your key area
we're soon going to be releasing a
little test that you can take that will
tell you which one is most relevant to
you and so you can take that and then
they can take it and then you can share
I think it's important to be vulnerable
about what yours is and your struggles
and then share your successes of how
you've beaten that over time and so a
transparency and vulnerability are
important I think when you're mentoring
I always learned from someone who's more
willing to share their struggles than
their successes right and and I identify
with people to say you know this was
really hard and this this is how I did
this and I seeked those people out so be
be vulnerable share some of those things
be transparent this is designed to be a
story that you can work through that you
can help mentor someone by sharing those
key mistakes and I wrote it in a story
form so that you could be entertained as
read it but also kind of like Jerry
Seinfeld's wife Jessica Seinfeld she
writes these great cookbooks for kids to
sneak in vegetables you know zucchini
and the chocolate chip cookies and so I
wrote it in a story form so that you
could entertain somebody who might not
even think they're being mentored but
then they learn they get their
vegetables as they go through the book
and so any way that you can use these
frameworks I think like this story may
help you mentor other people and then
you learn I learned so much more when
I'm mentoring someone else that's how I
learned that's personal
yeah I think that's an amazing tool like
if you had some kind of self-assessment
tool that you were given to your mentees
and then you know okay mistake five and
six are the ones that are keep gonna
keep coming up over and over again that
then as a mentor gives you the tools to
say okay hey you know a number five is
here it is you're making it again it's
an easy way to guide them so that's
that's super cool I want to give this
when is when is this tool coming out
probably on Monday because the book
comes out Tuesday so we'll be putting it
up on the site on Monday cool I'm gonna
share with my team I'm excited okay
Archie is asking I'm married skip and
really don't care much for my job how do
I get my family on board to realize how
important it is to get my business going
so that I can leave my job you know it's
so very important and obviously so many
people have a passion and they want to
do things so it's a very individual
circumstance right some people need to
have a certain amount of money saved up
or a certain safety net etc but but the
Y inside of you how do you capture that
with others how do you share that dream
with them they've got to catch it and
there are various ways to to get that to
happen well one is to talk about this
readiness right is your desire greater
than your distraction when you say that
what I hear in that is my family's the
distraction I have a desire piece but I
have this distraction so you've got to
work on that so that your desires hi and
how do you eliminate that distraction
now I don't recommend that you eliminate
your spouse that's not what I'm saying
but how do you bring the people around
you into that dream well work on your
desire you've got to sweep them up in a
way that they can see it as clearly as
you can
and sometimes that can happen early and
sometimes they may not see it until
later personality and other things but
doing all that I will say something else
learning to be passionate and working on
the job that you're miserable in can be
a key skill and it can be something that
will help you even in your own business
because you're gonna have the same days
in a different environment that will
pull you down and it may be awful it may
be miserable you may have a bad boss you
may have things that kind of tear you
know you aside but if you can learn to
be happy fulfilled and work through all
of that on your job it will fuel success
for you even when you launch your own
thing so I highly recommend that you
think about how am I going to to turn
that around and learn key things now
that will change my business in the
future yeah I just pulled the book out
while you were talking because it
reminds me of mistake number two which
we didn't touch on which was allowing
someone else to define your value and so
like do you define your own value or
does your spouse define your value and
deciding for yourself and so all of
these rules are great you know it's like
what is that is that two is that three I
was trying to find it so yeah it's like
defining your life for yourself I think
it's super important
jefra is writing in skip you're talking
about the why inside you how do you know
you're being true to yourself and
purpose you know there's a lot of ways
to define mistake number one of being
true to your purpose we work through
some of them in the in the companion
guides on the book of mistake comm so
that you can learn your purpose one of
the key ways that I find that I know I'm
in my purpose is my energy level right
so everything really if you if you're
really sensitive to that and you you're
working on yourself within you will you
will feel your energy
right and people will bring up your
energy or they'll bring it down right
one of the things I met Evan I first met
him in person boom like my energy Lana
right energy fuels so much who's around
you so if you're in your purpose your
energy is up your feeling your mood up
you're happy that will always be the
case and there's not
affecting your not always everything's
gonna be smooth but you'll feel your
energy
there are days when you go to work and
your energy is there and you feel the
passion and you feel like where did the
day go like I'm it was amazing and I
don't even feel like I worked right if
you look at Tim Ferriss 4-hour workweek
or whatever he calls it it's really of
course he works more than four hours but
it doesn't even count because he's so
excited about what he does so it's so
important to be thinking about your
energy
I find that when you're in your purpose
your energy is up and when you're not if
you're dragged into something and your
Energy's low and consistently low and
push down then you're not in your
purpose so you've got a re cut of look
for something that's driving you I love
it well guys it's crazy how quickly time
flies are already bumping up against the
clock go check out a book of mistakes
calm we've linked it up down in the
description below skip I know there's a
whole bunch of bonuses that come with
the pre-order just quickly touch on what
people get besides the book when they go
in they pre-order right now they get my
free book on ebook on leadership which
is leading with others in mind instead
of yourself great for entrepreneurs
small companies etc but they have
there's a book discussion guide there's
the leaders guide to the book of
mistakes so you can work it through with
a small group of people whether they're
working with you or for you or just your
family and then there are other
giveaways as well chapter from Tim
Sanders book an audio book on julen your
engagement by Kevin Caruso lots of
different bonuses that the book of
mistakes calm and happy to have people
check them out it is it is very exciting
to put this out and and to share this
and yeah it's it's it's something that
we want to inspire people and we want it
to be a book that inspires and then you
can give to others and say hey let's
talk about this just start discussions
like this because that's really what
fuels success get a couple people and
three or four people talking about some
of these principles and how they apply
to you and your future can change I love
it there's some quick questions about
formatting so I have the hardcover
version is this also ebook audible
what are the formats there's an audio
book there hardcover and you can also
get a key book as well so all formats
are out and my publishers done a great
job and and you should find it
everywhere awesome and Ben is this
asking the price what is the price 25 US
30 to 50 Canadian and then I guess eBook
audio guys can go check it out like
significant discounts right now I'm saw
most of the sites as you would imagine
get get the pre-order bonus now guys
thank you skip I know I know we went
like a little bit over I really
appreciate the time good luck in a new
book man thank you guys so much for
watching go check out book and mistakes
comm link in description I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and we'll see you soon